does showing up for work make you a
racist jerk
and their race obsession won't let up
even when it comes to naaman pups
welcome back to everything is racist
episode 6844
i'm your host suzanne summers
here's a study from social psychology
quarterly wow it comes out four times a
year just like my belly button
it's a medical thing
claims this thing claims that dogs with
typically white sounding names get
adopted from shelters faster
than dogs with black sounding names
which is terrible news for my poodle
jay-z
he's got 99 problems but testicles ain't
one
or two
[Laughter]
anyway i'm proud of that researchers say
it happens among pit bulls which they
called a breed that is stereotyped as
dangerous and racialized as black of
course academics applauded this research
uh one woman called it fascinating
research that supports the resiliency of
racialized names and the pervasiveness
of anti-blackness
well throw in a fat phobic reference and
she wins a free ice cream sundae
meanwhile another race takes
a professor at yale which is a school
for people who couldn't get into devry
complained that president biden working
while having kovid epitomizes white
supremacy
dr kim soo said it sets a bad example
for everyone that he cannot rest and
that people should take time off without
working through it
all right so being eager to work is a
white thing
and if you disagree you're racist
but at least we now know that p buddha
judge is definitely not a white
supremacist
you know
sue's comments came after uh biden's
announcement that he was getting a lot
of work done with kovid which came after
biden's announcement that he got cancer
from you know his windshield oil on his
windshield despite getting a stem cell
infusion over a jiffy lube
so joe how's that going
no no no you tell that lady from yale
i'm fine
i'm not working hard i'm hardly working
and uh just getting a few things done in
the office i'm a little tired but
uh
that's okay this covert thing's not
gonna get me i'm i'm like quadruple
boosted or something
and uh look i'm tough man
i grew up in delaware
i woke up every morning covered in oil
me and my friends would walk to school i
look like the creature from the black
lagoon
true true story that's a fact jack
also a great movie
aaron is it me or is it the people that
point this stuff out actually the racist
like
who would it cross anybody's mind that
there are black and white names for dogs
unless you were looking for it yeah it's
absolutely obscene and it just goes to
the point that everything is stupid now
when they say that everything is racist
i mean my dog's name is lincoln so for
sure they're gonna cancel me and that
was the same when i got him i didn't
name him that that's what he came with
yeah
in my defense but this is just this is
ridiculous and to joe biden all of a
sudden being this wry hard-working
president i've never seen him put on
such a show for doing his job this is
the most work this guy has done since
he's been at the white house
let alone the fact that he has coveted
we should be applauding the fact that
all of a sudden we've got somebody who
wants to do the job from a president who
hasn't done anything thus far yeah that
fair point
um
cat carl
is that a black or a white name
my dog's name is carl
for those of you that didn't know that
otherwise it didn't make much sense yes
uh i assume don't worry i'm here for you
um
i don't know carl cam wanted to name the
dog carl so i said okay because then i
got to just always say carl good to see
you when i see him which is something
that won't make sense to anyone who's
not seen billy madison hundreds of times
like i have
that's where it's from
yeah
all right yeah so oh that went nowhere
yeah well that's that's where
i'm just following your lead would you
care to add a comment about anything
other than your dog carl i i was uh just
curious
yeah uh yeah sure about anything yes
well i also have a cat named jeans yes
no i don't know this this stuff i think
uh
if it weren't for us talking about i
don't think anyone would i'm starting to
think it's like only exists so like fox
and friends and us and everyone else can
have things to talk about because
it's i don't think any real person is
like oh wow okay it's amazing it's
awesome other academics congratulating
themselves and then us mocking them
that's all that asks you know what we're
it's almost like we're all working for
each other yeah exactly you know joey
the beauty of the racist filter is like
you never run out of racist stuff you
could just keep picking new things this
uh this story uh the word you're looking
for
this it's it's this is a lady so i would
never talk to you you are absolutely a
lady and
but no
the idea on the topic of joe overworking
that what they've done is they've said
okay we're at a disadvantage as a class
of americans uh there aren't as many
fathers in the home there isn't as much
educational opportunities uh there's
ebonics as a form of linguistics these
put us at a disadvantage so what we're
going to do is we're going to take
everything that's traditionally american
and recast reclassify that as white
american so that rather than fixing our
own disadvantage as a group
we can say your advantage is actually
white supremacy and so rather than
everyone raising in here i get to talk
on this a little bit more because i am
from the re the jeff foxworthy version
of southern not the rep butler version
if you want to know what being
discriminated against looks like roll up
to a drive-through in california go hey
y'all got any more of them hamburgers on
there man i'd like to have a hot dog you
know and she looks and goes
what did you just say
you need money
and you talk about white names or black
names on a dog i grew up and this is i
do not these are the dogs i had we had
going up get down
danger ranger
fart
no lie and the last one was uh
i've reached the limit on beep so i'll
move on and we couldn't get our dogs
adopted my dad took my uncle's
bloodhound all the way to the top of
fort mountain to re-home him one time
and some redneck bear hunting recognized
him and brought him back we couldn't get
rid of our dogs
this idea that these no it's all bull
all right uh jamie as a racist who also
hates dogs
the story is in your wheelhouse care to
comment on uh
any uh facets of this i feel really
uncomfortable um
first of all i love how joey's dog's
names are all commands
okay i was my dad was smart that way get
down get down fart farted
[Laughter]
um i worry about joe
trying to work through covid because
remember what a terrible job he did when
he had uh no covert
[Laughter]
[Applause]
i don't know if joe does anything i feel
like if they said joe
take a break for a week he would go
exactly what is it that you want me to
stop doing
[Laughter]
and to your point i couldn't agree with
you more about it seems racist to point
out the dogs and plus we love dogs
you know like you like to call it
whatever kind of name i would think is
somebody you love or somebody you know
yeah and uh we've i i'm a huge fan of
dog we had to put a dog to sleep not
that long ago our dog floyd and i was
trying to get like a positive spin on it
and so i remember i remember i said to
my friend i go you know what he he
already sleeps 20 hours a day
what's four more
oh that's beautiful
there you go
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else